dude listen to my podcast if you're
listening to this after this go to
[ __ ] my podcast listen to my podcast
could I say something right now don't
don't don't don't look down out of my
pocket I'm not looking down on your pot
yeah the little army going I think your
podcast is great going on right now
alright sometimes I watch the clips on
YouTube I get it right and my guys might
not be as many as your guys maybe it is
my guys are okay dude and I slept and if
I be and that's not only that we have
little birds out there and my little
birds do have [ __ ] powers we have
artists they're artists yeah they're
[ __ ] hackers okay and they get
internet alright so don't change they
get it and don't challenge my when did I
do that because I don't like your tone
right now dude it's that I was gonna
plug yours
we're always your good friends here I
know we are but gonna see this - alright
how many times have I done yours I have
never had a guest
do you even know how his podcast works I
want to review yours I read watch clips
of yours
i watch clips of yours mmm I I'm a good
guy
i watch [ __ ] clips of yours he
watches clips
yeah Thank You Anya I won't be on it huh
but you're gonna open with listen to
tiger belly okay and I will because I'm
a good friend you will yep and I will
listen to that one whatever the next one
is if there's a whole [ __ ] thing I
know I don't listen to the whole thing
right okay I'm gonna say something else
to you and now I'm gonna look in your
eyes okay not that there is one but if
there was ever a war between you and
Theo von yeah if there was ever a war
sure you you have my assurance yeah this
is a slap Kingdom mm-hmm my people the
papayas mm-hmm we'll pack you like
you're the king of the north that's very
cool you're the king of the north and my
clan a my my people are on your team
thank you
[ __ ] the Rat King alas I love as a
person
Yeah right I love him as a rat King the
guy who gets
dick cut off in the reek yeah that's
true right yep
I think you're Jon Snow right that's
yeah right and he's the one that like
he's like I don't know what to do right
my sister was captured and then you give
him like man up go get or your sister do
what you have to do right yeah you're
that guy we're yeah yeah what were you I
am uh a little finger you're a guy wait
no be real on that show looking but you
watch Game of Thrones right I saw three
seasons oh you did yup guess what I do
after that I go I'm good I don't [ __ ]
do it how everyone does it I will not do
it how everyone does it
you're gonna make me keep watching this
[ __ ] show with all the families and
[ __ ] everyone's killing each other and
they're all friends but they're not
really friends and everyone dresses in
brown oh yeah dragons where are the
Dragons do okay were the dragons when do
the Dragons come in sea horse start
Delia with the Dragons nope
when somebody nah [ __ ] building when
somebody's like you got to watch your
show oh don't worry
get into it do it if I'm eating a
[ __ ] burger and and I eat a few bites
and they're like dude by the 10th bite
you're rocking with that burger you know
what kind of guy you are spike Pam it's
either delicious or it's not that's it
well you're making love you nut first
then now you're doing a guy because you
know what I do friend what I build to
the nut right I like I like to build up
I have a feeling you don't build to the
nut
oh I have a feeling that you a you have
it on your unwise about the situation
thank you so much because I didn't know
what I was gonna say there and I used
unwise and kind of say this law on top
of that too this is that I know you
first of all that's your wallet hell
yeah dude can I see it what do you you
know what I [ __ ] [ __ ] no I just want
to look ok that's your wallet yep
give up give them I got to put it on the
table cuz if I sit on it I'll get
scoliosis
my [ __ ] not stupid I know yeah if I
put it in the front people are like
we're we're sponsored by this company
yeah dude I I just seen that [ __ ] yeah I
seen that should I do gave me one you
gonna give me one no I was gonna give
you one but not I was gonna give you one
but not no I gave it moves away but I'll
take that one
are you gonna give it away no I'll keep
it yeah there we go as map flexes
accordingly I get it yeah as long as he
doesn't say anything in Cremona okay all
right hey Matt good man what's up well
tell him I'm doing my podcast with Chris
D'Elia right now what's up Matt wait
what
because I'll see you later bye bye it's
awesome yeah cuz he doesn't want to be
yeah he does want to incriminate himself
no but oh no it's beyond that no agents
want to be any kind of artist at all
right and I want to say something about
my agent because I never talked about
him and I know people don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care you know you know when I
was um 28 I met him 27 years old and he
was just a mailroom guy at Girish and he
used to hang out the comedy store and he
always he looked at me one day I was a
just an open mic er because when I'm an
agent one day I'm gonna wrap you and
winter work together and I didn't
believe him and he's my agent now and he
just called me and he's a friend and
that's why when I did listen listen this
story's over
it's okay it's not over because I don't
say something else
[ __ ] tells us to hey [ __ ] you wet
lips yeah like I know your litter so wet
on wet I know I got picked for the wet
is like that creature you know a little
wet lips is dry lips my lips I'm never
having that they're so wet it's gonna be
[ __ ] crazy
by the time I'm yeah he's got no lips
he's got no lip I mean he's gotta stop
talking about that bad it's not that man
you don't talk about hey like if
somebody's moving their hands if
somebody's listen to their hands yeah
don't talk about hands I talk about
hands if somebody has no hands I talk
about hands do you shake it how about
when somebody's got like a hand
that's not a full hand and they don't
warn you and they shake your hand I know
that I'd like not [ __ ] yourself attend
up and you're shaking a finger
how much would like the Mentalist are
like Darren brown just know though like
well I saw it in his eyes
he was scared you not I mean yeah that's
[ __ ] man when someone when you shake
someone's hand and you feel your body
jump out of your body but you're like
wait a minute I think I kept it together
right
hey man dude I'm gonna shake your hand
but my hands all [ __ ] up or give him
your left yeah or I will shake your hand
but I don't have one right what would
you say
well I have a friend that has that mmm
and my thing was to always just do it
harder and feel all the bone ice I just
like call it out without words yeah yeah
yeah yeah I get what kind of yeah
they're like I got get it do it I get
what you get what kind of guy you're
like a real man like they know then that
he's a real man oh you know I am make me
feel like his yes no all right so why is
it the shocker yeah this is my hand and
I don't realize it oh nice to meet you
yeah that's how you do it yep for [ __ ]
sake okay yeah are you doing yeah but
you squeeze it and just there's no wink
but it you give that yeah they don't
have the wing wink you have to wait
y'all are the feeling yep wow that's an
interesting way of doing is great too
awkwardness yeah you know I you know we
should really take a moment yeah Chris
I'm in already and I don't know what
you're gonna say I love taking moments
we should take a moment and just um
appreciate that we all have our body
parts mm-hmm you know mm-hmm when you're
peeing mm we should appreciate it mm-hm
yeah cuz we have penises you know you're
just walking around we you know we have
our health oh you know yeah we get in
week we get in they just listen mm-hmm
we get into this
like our careers okay you know mean and
me me where's ours right there are a lot
of times you just have to look around
and you know you have your fingers your
feet to walk on right you know you have
your little animals running around right
we have [ __ ] okay this is you just
would keep going if I was like okay just
keep going
how about that you don't have a trash
can in your bathroom though you don't
have a trash can in that bathroom that's
very much this one yeah
no when I went to the hallway where did
George gums putting the a/c on you
sweating are you sweating yeah you have
three layers on bro we're always
sweaters I gotta take it I'm sweating
like I'm good I'm good you are I love
being hot
[Music]